hi my name is Claire I hope what my
YouTube videos have done is help people
realize that they can be a normal human
being they can be whatever the hell they
want to be and be sick I don't think
that I've lived any less of a beautiful
life than your average healthy gel my
name is Claire Weinland and I have
cystic fibrosis the cystic fibrosis is a
genetic disease both terminal and
progressive which means as you get older
cystic fibrosis gets worse and it's also
terminal which means that downward hale
will end in death when I was born my
life expectancy was around 10 years old
so then the life expectancy was pushed
to 18 and that 19 and now mid to late
20s I realized a lot of people with CF
are really ashamed of having CF it
doesn't have to be this like dark kid
and the secret that you're dying on my
youtube channel I've covered stuff like
what it's like to actually be in a coma
how to talk to people who are sick what
not to say to people horrific stuff like
that sorry this was so depressing here's
a little joke to make it better
what is the biggest downside of sudden
unexpected death being unable to delete
your search history trying to explain
how cystic fibrosis feels without
sounding like you're being overly
dramatic and like depressing is hard it
really feels like you have sand in your
lungs and overall you just feel heavy
and tired and my friends say I'm like a
grumpy old man and it's interesting
looking at you know the way that you
other people live their lives which is
you know they've never really had to
think about that that's never been a
constant in their life so I think
fundamentally at the end of the day
doesn't matter really whether you're
scared of death or whether you're scared
of paying your bills we all have things
in our life that are just completely
foreign that's the reason that death is
so scary is because it's so foreign I
think I want people to take away from my
life the notion that they can live lives
that they're proud of whether or not
they think our life is normal
[Music]